our character has started to hollow and
it all started with y'all Oh our
champion of Ash welcome home
this pilgrim with a debt in death hardly
deserves to behold this divine flame and
I never would have had you not taken me
into your service I thank you dearly for
this and assure you of my real service
as I have said I was once a sorcerer
alas the magic of Londo is a far cry
from the wonders of in I'm but I can
teach you what I know perhaps more
importantly I believe that I can help
tease out your true strength
we pilgrims of LAN door are keenly aware
but those branded by the dark sign
possess something quite special then
shall we begin
bearer of the dark sign let your true
strength trying so drawing out your true
strength at yeol you'll do a level
completely for free without any soul
requirement however it also subtly and
without any notification creates a dark
sigil found within your key slot in your
inventory the dark sigil description
reads a black gaping hole in the flesh
that resembles the brand of an undead
the darkness of humanity seeps from this
bottomless pitch black hole the gap
filled by the accumulation of the curse
and once this dark sigil appears and is
triggered by yeol every subsequent death
will cause you to hollow further and you
can now track the level of your
hollowing on your stat screen this dark
sigil will never heal but there is a
tale told of a fire keeper who returned
from the abyss and brought great comfort
to a bearer of the curse
after getting 20,000 souls you can buy
the tower key from the handmaiden and
then you can explore the bell tower
behind Firelink shrine we journey up
there and we find what remains of this
old legendary Firekeeper soul of a fire
keeper who is said to have returned from
the abyss this fire keeper preserves the
bonfire and serves its champion she is
said to have soothed and accepted the
dark sigil which has tainted her soul
and yet her soul will one day embed
itself in the bosom of another fire
keeper the tower key reads the bell
tower is the grave of fire keepers past
when a fire keeper has served her
purpose she is led to true darkness
where she enjoys a long deserved sleep
as we journey down I got really lucky I
looked over the edge here and I saw that
a corpse had been thrown down here but
it got caught on the edge and it's
another fire keeper and below are
hundreds more this apparently is the
fate of fire keepers who serve the flame
the fire keepers were robbed of light to
better serve as vessels for souls only
those who cherish the writhing searing
darkness were given the fire keepers
black attire the estus ring reads this
ring was entrusted to a certain fire
keeper but in the end she never met her
champion and the ensuing tragic farce
became a favorite tale of the masses I
hope you guys are keeping up with me
this is a really
law of eeehh pisode and apparently this
fire keeper who returned from the abyss
existed during ludley of corland cycle
before he linked the fire presumably
ah found her did we and the black eyes
that shimmer within I see
tis as if it were but yesterday we did
all we could to spare her from much has
happened since may happen I should
apprise thee of what the thin light of
these eyes might reveal to the eyeless
fire keeper scene of betray things never
intended for her Ken visions of this
ages end
treat the fire keeper not with
discourtesy she is much likely prisoners
book kept to link the fire there's a
story here for sure but parts are
missing who did call and seek to spare
her from who was the betrayer and what
did this fire keeper who returned from
the abyss apparently see
passion one this is much like what lies
within me then let it find its own place
within my bosom she will understand we
are both via keepers after all forgive
me sister may the flames guide thy way
healing the dark sigil costs a
ridiculous amount of souls and even
after its removed your points of
hollowing still remain and there is
always the option to acquire more dark
sigils from y'all as far as I can tell
the only effect of hollowing is that it
allows you to occasionally acquire
another dark sigil from y'all and this
lets you level up for free so in a sense
it's a way to lessen the pain of dying
so many times this is the best theory I
have and I've gone painstakingly over
every piece of footage I have but
there's more because after five free
levels and five dark sigils y'all says
you have attained ample strength and
that soon all will become clear and then
after reloading the area watching over
yours newfound corpse was a woman named
urea oh pretty
art thou good yours master
I am urea of Londo a close friend of his
thanks to the old soul is redeemed allow
me to express my gratitude in his stead
another matter that a lord are the knot
bearer of the dark sigil and our lord of
hollows for the time thou remains our
lord we of lund or shall serve thee and
I of course am also thine the notable
items she sells are the purging stone
which seems to say that it will cure the
visual effects of hollowing and the dark
hand from Dark Souls 1 there's also two
rings that change you into human or
phantom form and the lond or Braille
divine tome which teaches us dark
miracles if we can find someone to read
it and I know where to find her hmm
another one of those I'm kindled are you
all you faceless undead behaving as if
you deserve respect hopeless the whole
lot of you like little moths fluttering
towards a flame siegmeyer and Andrei
they aren't the only Souls to be reborn
this man from Kareem just quoted a line
from war trek of Dark Souls 1 and both
of them are obsessed with the fire
keepers you like poking around in cells
do you a very genteel taking an interest
in her of you which is a lost cause
couldn't even become a fire Kiba after I
brought her all this way and got her
already she's beyond repair I tell you
who is that someone there anyone oh
please
whoever you are touch me the dark
surrounds me nibbles at my flesh oh yes
there you are so close indeed and I am
not entirely alone just yet
Arina unwillingly eventually reads the
Braille tome to us and she can teach us
three hexes hexes are confirmed dark
blade valve silenced and dead again
isn't it better to burn a soul vessel
than be a dirty hex earscope yeah I
could try a dex build so around this
point I started feeling really pressured
I knew I was at the end of my
pre-release session with Dark Souls 3 so
in a last-ditch effort to just learn
something more I kill everyone I can
think of in the shrine arena drops the
tower key and then her prior captor
makes good on his promise and he
ambushes you in the shrine for killing
her you get his hammer and his shield
when you kill him the handmaiden
respawns but every time you kill her she
increases the prices of her wares in
revenge
I think the tower key ended up costing
like 40,000 instead of 20,000 it was
insane don't do this Andrey does not
give a [ __ ] when you attack him I guess
he's been blacksmithing for like
generations and he's been smithing stuff
through countless apocalypses one undead
slashing at him isn't going to stop him
though when you do kill him he refuses
to help you at all so don't do this
either
and finally we kill urea you all knows
not of thy folly a hollow need not be
allowed no one so weak shall ever wear
our bus I found it interesting that she
shares her name with urea of demon souls
who in that game was a witch who
practiced the dark arts that stem from
emotion I always remember that bit of
dialogue and it's interesting urea of
Dark Souls 3 has connections to hexes
and dark miracles that also reference
emotion in many descriptions cough this
makes it click with us that LAN door is
New Londo from Dark Souls 1 a land where
the four kings were corrupted by the
whisperings of caf
the home of the darkwraiths who look to
be ruled over by a Dark Lord which lines
up with the end of Dark Souls 1 as you
become a Dark Lord who embraces the
curse a lord of hollows so much more to
talk about but no time the final boss of
the demo is the cursed great wood I
don't know about others but this fight
was really disappointing for me his
attacks did really low damage for how
easy they were to avoid however he does
drop something hugely important he drops
a transposing kiln
oh we like it is a transposing kill
Dyke recession transposition is the art
of extracting and coalescing the essence
of a soul the most interesting item here
is the black eye ring I think because it
gives you health back on successive hits
which means it encourages a more
aggressive play style which is awesome
the demo ends with another fight against
a boreal Knight and this one is down the
elevator where we first met
Sigrid the crestfallen night calls this
path the path to Aldrich st. of the deep
there is a lot more I want to talk about
and I wish I wasn't under time
constraints because come March 24th I'll
be able to do a much better job than
what I have done here and that's going
to be exciting March 24th is when the
Japanese version releases by the way but
for now this is all I have to show I
really did try my best with all of this
I've only got four hours of sleep every
night so thank you all for watching so
much and I'll see you again soon
time to sleep